I said a while ago if Joe Biden does  something on student loan debt and if  Joe Biden does something on cannabis  those would be really significant  accomplishments and a very good reason  to vote for Democrats in November and  maybe even to justify Joe Biden's  reelection in 2024 if he runs which it  increasingly looks like he will he has  now done something on both of those  things  I think we have no choice but to vote  for Democrats in November and to at  least give Joe Biden the opportunity to  say I've earned another four years and  if he wants that we should seriously  consider voting for him again as well  that's my view as of right now because  he did the things that I mentioned